there's no need to break into the
Watergate Hotel anymore the landmark
property is opening its doors for the
first time in nine years and the new
owners are doing everything they can to
make sure guests get the full flavor of
its scandalous past here with us from
Washington with a look inside is Jack
Cohen the founder of Euro Capital
properties and the new owner of the
Watergate Hotel Jack I really want to
ask you why exactly you bought the
Watergate Hotel but I guess the answer
is partially obvious well when we bought
the Watergate Hotel it was quite a an
eyesore everybody had seen it everybody
was afraid of it it was such a challenge
but we saw tremendous opportunity and
today I believe we have one of the best
hotels in the world
he spent 125 million dollars on a
facelift how do you intend on reaping
that back pretty quickly and do you want
it to be one of the destination hotels
in Washington DC well it was a big
investment but I think the city really
needs a property like that
that is a true luxury lifestyle hotel we
had a niche in the market we just opened
with a soft opening and were already
fully booked Jack just tell us what 125
million dollars does when it comes to
applying a facelift for a hotel what
would the most significant changes and
challenges you faced the hotel had many
challenges and we spent the money where
where the challenges were we created a
very large Grand Ballroom 7,000 square
feet in order to do that we had to
demolish the garden in the middle of the
Watergate complex and raised it seven
feet the hotel was very clustered back
then it didn't have any views on the
water so we spent a lot of money also
opening it up and creating the views on
the water and lastly the hotel we
thought has a tremendous potential to
become a urban resort with its views on
the water again so we created six
different terraces a rooftop terrace
with 360 views is going to be the best
rooftop bar in town we also have a
restaurant terrace and a pre-function
terrace so the the resort feel is very
on the presents in the hotel Jack how
important was having a 60s vibe this
retro feel because I understand also
that you've created uniforms or the
person behind the mad
and uniforms has created your your
costumes or your uniforms should I say
so the Watergate rebuilding is a story
of love and passion we fell in love with
the architecture we so right away the
potential to recreate the glamour of the
960 60s really pretty much immediately
the Watergate was a tremendous glamor
spot back when it opened in the early
60s and Moretti had done all these
curves it was back then a revolution in
the architectural world when the
Watergate complex was built so for us
it's a it's a top to bottom 1960s
branding we believe were were fun we
believe were energetic and we bring the
same level of luxury and and we're a
glamour and we've created the rules of
the Watergate one of them is champagne
is a food group that's glamour